okay so as the weeks go on we are slowly
getting more and more DC EU updates and
the Rock is now finally broken in
Silence about what's happening with
Black Adam he released a statement last
night talking about the conclusion of
his meeting with James Gunn and it
doesn't sound too good Black Adam of
course released back at the end of
October and it had a big post-credit
scene with Henry Cavill returning in the
aftermath of it Dwayne started hyping up
a Black Adam vs Superman movie but those
plans went down the Dwayne when Cavill
was kicked to the curb James Gunners got
a lot of backlash for it with pretty
much everyone kicking off that Cavill is
now gone because of this it seemed
inevitable that The Rock was out too and
by the sounds of it he pretty much is
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down his statement and also
going over our thoughts on what it means
for the future of the DCU I know I'm
doing a lot of DC videos at the moment
but I actually put out a poll last night
on Twitter asking whether I should cover
this or the across the spider verse
poster today and the people have spoken
so blame yourself you idiot this is your
fault also follow follow me on Twitter
and from now on only people subscribe to
heavy spoilers poo can vote in polls now
unlike most videos where I'll read out
the whole statement and then talk about
it at the end I think I'm just gonna
respond to what what's said in a bit by
bit anyway the rock statement goes a
little something like this my passionate
friends well mate at least buy me dinner
first I wanted to give a long-awaited
Black Adam update regarding the
characters featuring the new DC Universe
James Gunn and I connected and Black
Adam will not be in their first chapter
of Storytelling however DC and seven
bucks have agreed to continue exploring
the most valuable ways that Black Adam
can be utilized in future DC Multiverse
chapters now I think this is quite an
important chapter and though a lot of
people are saying that the rock is out I
I actually think this kind of states the
opposite however I don't think it's a
guarantee and there's a number of things
going on with what he says here now just
a lesson in life mate just a lesson if
you ever a corporate setting like a job
interview or you're asking your boss
something and you've been rejected from
something and you follow up and go well
we'll kind of have like an extra days
holiday or something if they then say I
can try or yeah I'll try and get that
done then that person has absolutely no
intention of doing it and they're just
saying it to shut you up and basically
getting used to the idea that it might
not happen so that you don't complain
when it doesn't they've already knocked
you down and they're just saying yeah
I'll try to to at least make you feel
like you've achieved something but you
haven't now that's the kind of feeling I
get with these constant statements and
there's been a number of them that have
talked about how the movies and
characters have been shut down but that
DC is gonna try and do something with
them in the future now the Multiverse
thing can really go one of two ways
eligan's plan is that they do a reboot
of the universe and then slowly build
towards an event-like crisis on infinite
Earths that has everyone come back or
and this is a big ore they try this
stuff with the new people and if it
doesn't work out it can just say [ __ ] it
and Multiverse the entire thing this
means that they can bring the old
characters back and at least try and
Salvage what was working from time to
time before again did say that he
planned on working with Henry in the
future and maybe the crisis could save
DC from being in the crisis that it's in
now now personally I'm leaning more
towards a ladder because I don't see why
they'd reboot the entire universe and
throw everyone out if they weren't
planning on that being successful I feel
like the old dceu will very much be the
plan B for this if it doesn't work out
and then they'll find a way to bring
them back if gun's plan doesn't work
kind of mental that the Rocks spend 15
years of his life trying to get Black
Adam made and he got potentially fired
two months after its release like it was
released on the 21st of October and it's
now the 21st of December it's a mental
anyway he continues to say James and I
have known each other for years and have
always rooted for each other to succeed
it's no different now and I will always
root for DC and Marvel to win and win
big
now I have seen a lot of focus on this
Marvel comment and it might hint on him
switching sides to the place that
doesn't constantly tell the fans their
Chumps I think no it's basically him
just saying that he wants both Studios
to win because he loves comic book
movies might be him basically doing that
thing though where you throw a little
shot at your ex by posting a status
about how you've been looking at another
girl but moving on you guys know me and
I have very thick skin and you can
always count on me to be direct with my
words these decisions made by James and
DC leadership represent their vision of
DCU through their creative lens after 15
years of Relentless hard work to finally
make Black Adam I am very proud of the
film we delivered for fans worldwide I
will always look back on pan reaction to
Black Adam with tremendous gratitude
humility and love we did great excuse me
do my very passionate and vocal Black
Adam superhero genre fans I love you
thank you and I will always listen to
you and do my best to deliver and
entertain you what a hell of a month now
we need some Terror Mata and Terra Mana
is basically tequila which probably done
here sir have a productive week and
happy holidays to you and your families
D now it kind of sounds like they just
took him into a room had Henry Cavill
walk out and tell him it's all about one
of these days yeah I'd love it if a
celebrity just came out and was like
James Gunn's a [ __ ] idiot shouldn't
have been kicked out his universe is
[ __ ] terrible but they're not good
but they're not gonna do that because
they're those guys now James Gunn then
replied to this by saying love at the
Rock and I'm always excited to see what
he and seven bucks do next can't wait to
collaborate soon so doing the whole
teasing the future thing and who knows
gun might want to get his Universe
established and then bring them back
again though I don't see why you do that
unless your stuff isn't working now gun
has put out numerous Twitter threads and
there was one the other day that dropped
after the worst several reports that all
the big names were out but that he was
keeping the suicide squad and Peacemaker
cast this rub people the wrong way
including me because it seemed like he
was just keeping his own stuff and
getting rid of everyone else I've always
said that though I don't want a dce
reboot I think that if they're looking
to reboot then they need to reboot the
entire thing because then you're just
gonna have ties to the old stuff that
you apparently don't want this stuff is
all still linked and it'll end up
becoming even more confusing if they
don't just have a ties for example the
Justice League showed up at the end of
Peacemaker Peacemaker was in suicide
squad or this or The Suicide Squad where
whatever it is that had Harley Quinn
Walla and Rick flag who were in the
previous Suicide Squad movie that movie
came off the back of Superman's death
and BBs and it had Aflac in The Flash in
it so tied in with BBs which tied in
with Man of Steel and therefore it's
kind of like yeah this stuff is really
confusing if you only say that
Peacemaker and Suicide Squad are the
Canon now now James Gannon said that he
will be keeping what works and getting
rid of what doesn't so his stuff
according to him I've gotten so many
bloody Twitter arguments over the last
couple of days with people saying that
gun stuff is the only things that have
done well and that critically it makes
sense to focus on his things however
when you compare the scores to the other
DCU movies that are probably getting
wiped then they are about the same plus
those movies actually made money as well
with Aquaman being a billion dollar
franchise and Wonder Woman making 822
million even in the case of Wonder Woman
1984 and Suicide Squad they both made
about the same amount of money too both
were released on HBO Max day one but 84
had a lot of countries in lockdown due
to it being dropped over Christmas on
HBO Max's Suicide Squad got 4.2 million
viewers though whereas Wonder Woman 1984
got 14 million which is quite a big
difference according to Sama TV
Peacemaker got 638 000 viewers in its
first four days and if we compare that
to She-Hulk that got 5.74 million now
like suicide squad and Peacemaker but I
don't think the arguments said that only
gun stuff is successful and again if
you're gonna get rid of that stuff you
have to get rid of everything and start
again in my opinion we can all bring our
opinions into this stuff but looking at
the numbers they don't lie and that's
them in black and white anyway in
reaction to people kicking off a gun put
out this one of the things Peter and I
were aware of when we took the jobs as
heads of DC Studios was a certain
minority of people online that could be
well uproarious and unkind to say the
least I don't know if Henry Cavill fans
are the minority but our choices for the
DCU are based upon what we believe is
best for the story and best for the DC
characters who have been around for
nearly 85 years perhaps these choices
are great perhaps not so it's confident
but they are made with sincere hearts
and integrity and always with this story
in mind no one loves to be harassed to
called names but to be frank we've been
through significantly worse
disrespectful outcry will never ever
affect our actions we were aware there
would be a period of turbulence when we
took this gig and we knew that we would
sometimes have to make difficult and not
so obvious choices especially in the
wake of the fracturers nature of what's
come before us but this means little to
us in comparison to our jobs as artists
and custodians and helping to create a
wide and wonderful future for DC now
going wasn't asked about whether this
stuff about suicide squad getting kept
was true and he said I keep seeing posts
with his untrue Theory I'm not
requesting everyone except the suicide
squad so it could be taken one of two
ways either The Suicide Squad is also
completely recast or there are other
parts of the DCU that haven't been
recast either Gal Gadot still hasn't
said anything you posted posted a
picture of herself in an orange top but
we don't want that we want a big
paragraph of text on a black background
letting us know what's happening and I
do think that you know even though she's
posted this yes I do think that the next
person to issue a statement will be her
I imagine that if the flash Aquaman and
Shazam 2 hadn't had so much money put
into them that they'd probably be
announced as being out by now but [ __ ]
knows what they're doing and they have
cut cameos with Kevin Aflac in those
upcoming movies as well so I think that
they're gonna be all out gun did say
that gal wasn't booted but again it
could be open to interpretation I mean
that they gave her the whole oh mate
we'll bring you back mate would you just
need to ask my mom if he can come round
for tea or honestly I'll invite you to
my birthday party we can be best made to
it we'll bring you back which is making
other movies without you Gunners also
stated that they're still doing
elseworld stories and though this could
just be stuff like the Batman 2 and
Joker 2 they might might bring some of
these actors back for other stuff
talking Black Adam vs Superman bloody
make it now Robert Mai Bennett and
Christian harloff actually brought up
some great points when talking about the
whole thing and I think it really sums
up the situation and actually add some
stuff to all of our talk what do you
think about how do you interpret James
Gunn's tweet here and is it going to be
a complete Clean Slate is it going to be
Clean Slate sorta but they're going to
bring some pieces over what do you take
at this point well I would say first you
have to look at I mean this this is a
business it's all about what is made
money
Aquaman I would look to Aquaman and go
okay Aquaman made a billion dollars they
have Aquaman the lost kingdom which by
the way was finished a long time ago
they're deep deep into the post on that
movie
they know if it's great enough
well if it looks to be as great as the
first movie why would you get rid of a
billion dollar franchise
I mean if the movie reboot or not from a
studio perspective you have already
reached that billion dollar level with
the first movie there's no reason to
suspect if the next movie is great it's
also James Juan and Peter saffron
producing why would a producer want to
get rid of that franchise especially if
they're looking at it going great
let's make a third one you know so I
could absolutely see we've already had
Jason Momoa say thank you James gun
everyone's like oh he's going to play
Lobo
I would say that James gun snowing no
we're going to finish your Aquaman
Trilogy we're gonna we're gonna finish
that we're gonna give you that Aquaman
movie and then maybe you'll be logo who
knows because why would you dump that
and I would even say this John
as as much as Wonder Woman 84 was I
hated it and it obviously didn't do well
the first one did well 800 great if so
they didn't like Patty Jenkins her take
on it but remember she didn't even
develop the first Aquaman I mean the
first Wonder Woman she stepped in and
took over
so Gal Gadot people like Gal Gadot as
Wonder Woman maybe they have plans to do
they
well I mean I would say the first one
was sorry majority but but I would say I
would I would say look and also
Peacemaker you know they're getting that
season too
so in addition to the the DC reboot will
happen with Superman as we know James
Gunn's writing it but that reboot might
come at the end of 2024 or even the
beginning of 2025 they might just say
reboot time is 2025. we're going to get
another Aquaman in we're going to get
another Wonder Woman movie in we're
getting Peacemaker in we might even make
another Suicide Squad coming I can't see
that happen I mean I don't know if
they're going to do all of it but why
would you get rid of Aquaman
because it's part of a bigger machine
that's not working but that worked that
one piece oh man yes do you do you pump
the brakes on the entire operation that
is not working because one piece is
working I I don't know same argument can
be made for Henry Cavill because
everybody maybe Man of Steel itself I
mean you and I both really love Man of
Steel right now all three all three of
us but the thing with Man of Steel the
difference with Henry Cavill is that
even though that movie made what let's
say a disappointing 500 million which is
still a good a good number
by the ill will that from a lot of
people from getting rid of him already
it has done if you're gonna make a move
like that you got to make a move all in
because if you because then people are
going to go well wait a minute you're
keeping Aquaman but you got rid of Henry
Cavill Henry Cavill is a piece that was
working maybe his movies in Batman and
Superman he didn't get a chance to shine
the way that he did but Henry Cavill was
working Henry Cavill was the piece that
was getting everyone excited I still
think that they could have done
something inside of like a a different
timeline to bring him back I understand
I'm with you John in the fact that I
think that I'm really bummed that he's
gone I understand why they made the
choice but I still think they could have
made it work but they don't want to go
in that direction I think that's the
same thing with with Patty Jenkins and
Aquaman and all that so some really
great points there and I think they
could potentially set a date for the
reboot and wrap some of this stuff up
I've always said I wish they'd done a
movie to kind of close things off rather
than just doing what they're doing which
is announcing stuff on Twitter I know
the fox X-Men Universe it gets a lot of
hate but they actually managed to reboot
past whilst continuing Wolverine solar
movies and having a send-off for the
older characters they did all that in
the universe so that fans wouldn't be
annoyed and I just kind of wish that DC
took that strategy too again I think if
they're gonna reboot they need to fully
reboot because there's gonna be people
who say they want the other stuff back
and it could still technically be in
Universe because of what we discussed
before anyway that's the video and let
me know what you think has DC hit rock
bottom or are you excited for what's to
come we are in in competition right now
and giving away Dawn of the Dead and
Black Adam at 3 subscribers on the 15th
of January and all you have to do to be
when the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on drop a comment below
with your thoughts on the news if you
want something else to watch we've got
another video on screen right now you
might not want to watch another DC Video
so there's something else here break
down a Logan go check that out right
after this by the way thanks for
sticking to the video I've been Paul
I'll see you next time take care peace
foreign